In order to solve full self-driving properly,...
...you actually just have to solve real-world AI.
Because you're like, what are the road networks designed to work with?
They're designed to work with a biological neural net, our brains,...
...and with vision, our eyes.
And so, in order to make it work with computers,...
...you basically need to solve real-world AI and vision.
Because we need cameras and silicon neural nets...
...in order to have self-driving work for a system that was designed for eyes...
...and biological neural nets.
I guess when you put it that way,...
...it's quite obvious that the only way to solve full self-driving...
...is to solve real-world AI and sophisticated vision.